[Music]
and that escalated quickly News whoa
submitted by Mickey moose What's Up mo
see a viral video of a bullied boy wins
the hearts of celebrities and then a ton
of backlash ensues as more information
comes out okay every time I see someone
got bullied I roll my eyes if you didn't
get bullied
you're freaking weird Jew you never got
bully did you now you're getting bullied
who wouldn't bully you're [ __ ] told
her mother other even taller brother
yeah that's that it's not the same see
just cuz she was cool at school doesn't
mean at home she'd have a tough time she
was in volleyball I was a emo kid emo
kid yes okay I would've made fun of you
big nerd you ever the hair cover one eye
that's awesome I want to see photos of
that like Nicki to like I would have
never hung out with Nicki in high school
I feel like Nicki would have been like a
Caesar wishes no she was a hip-hop did
you have a green and black striped shirt
Oh like Kurt Cobain's that was such an
emotion in black stripes you have a
checkered van slip-ons I did and always
were like door shirts or Led Zeppelin
shirts we had like the ball necklace no
no that's gone I was gone that was me
that's God for sure at that time for us
at least it was gone and then hot topic
was like yeah ball gag is like what
topic wasn't as cool as it is now
or I don't need wait no it's not our
generation was the only time it was cool
it was cool when we were coming up for
yeah yeah so I got all my [ __ ] from Hot
Topic and I was like no one else is
getting this [ __ ] I just loved it
because all these kids are like there
they had that mentality and then you
know it was a fortune 500 company I
never get all my [ __ ] at secondhand
stores so I thought was way cool that is
actually better okay so this story is
this kid named Keaton Jones he's loving
years old from Knoxville Tennessee
I like Tennessee Tennessee what kind of
names Keaton huh yeah I'm trying getting
them and giving it a try you're bullying
em they started just to have you seen
there yes so his mother Kimberly Jonz
posted a video of her son crying about
being bullied on her Facebook page and
it was viewed over 20 million times
before she made her facebook private
celeb started to offer support there
were huge names like Justin Bieber Snoop
Dogg Chris Evans even invited him out
like he this kid Captain America oh yeah
ken's invited about invited about to the
premiere of the Avengers and like almost
a lot of celebrities are just inviting
this kid's like you know you have a
friend into the ice then with Keaton oh
I want to be bullied
football players I do want to be
politics so many opportunities come from
bullying like you get bullied and then
you get you get Fame snow does you know
who I am
yep what if I get bullied you start
bullying one of us really like I thought
that's what we're doing here what was
the contents of the video like what
happened to him where like it touched so
many celebrities touch them so much so
the video about to show you is the video
that went viral of Keaton crying and
then attached to that is responses by
celebrity Carter Oh it'll all be in one
video why did that boy what what's the
point of why he's not joining
taken yes to people and finding a way to
make men do not okay
what did I say to you [ __ ] I'm going to
[ __ ] hell what they do tell you at
lunch Bill Cosby that is so sad through
it Hannah is it just you yep where is it
other kids too that feel that way Shane
it so they're good shoe
how's that make you feel I think they do
it to be love fish you know what they do
to other people can don't okay try
things that are different don't need to
be criticized about it it's not their
fault but if you are made fun of just
don't don't let it bother you stay stuck
like this damn it I guess Oh see Keaton
who's from Tennessee I am what's wrong
with this world oh wow celebrities like
Justin Bieber the fact that he still has
the sympathy and compassion for other
people when he's going through it
himself is a testament to who he is
and actress Hailee Steinfeld hey Keaton
its Haley here I just wanted to say I
think you are amazing
he's been invited to movie premieres and
Broadway shows Wow mr. wrights on
twitter the support is overwhelmingly he
is doing good and loving the awareness
his video hashtags stand with Keith
that's really cool because it's like a
big [ __ ] you to all his buddies I will
say all I said was that every time I
hear someone got bullied I say everyone
got bullied but this kid it's a little
different yeah yeah and like a really
personal one and kids now I feel like
bullying got to like a really bad level
because of social media like for us yeah
we all got bullied but at least for us
it's like it stayed at school you know
what I mean like if I know if that kids
bullying you at school it stays or you
go home and now it's like you have a
different set of friends at home or like
your your your chilling with your mom or
your brothers or whatever and they love
you but then or your room even yeah home
you have you still yeah you get
notifications that your being boys do
you think he knows how to deal with all
this new Fame so if he came from like
get him milk poured on him during lunch
and now the same girls are like umhum
mad [ __ ]
does he know you think my needs like
rubbing shoulders always celebrities is
he gonna is he gonna go to his head and
he's gonna you know I know I hope so
I'll be monster so the second parts of
the story so since he inspired an entire
nation just in one day a lot of people
started digging in Kimberly Jonz
Facebook page and so they found some old
photos this is their facebook status it
says so they're southern yeah Tennessee
okay so it says deer butthurt Americans
if you aren't bleeding no bones are
sticking out and you can breathe stop
crying for the love for the love some
folks clearly never picked a switch and
before y'all start talking to me about
metaphorical emotional financial or her
store or historical blood and brokenness
don't join up group hashtag you'll need
some porch therapy hashtag coffee with
Jesus hashtag sentence hashtag fine
and so I don't I don't understand what
is the dirt basically no it's not okay
because because she she has she likes
the Confederate play like an ironic
thing here so she is not very
compassionate about other people's views
I met a guy from Tennessee right at the
airport you remember Tennessee Bart yeah
that he so he was this super weird
redneck that he told me like he used to
ride donkeys everywhere when he was a
kid they didn't really have cars and he
goes but I didn't [ __ ] him though then
his name was tennis his name was
Tennessee yeah yeah and he pulled up his
like [ __ ] belly and he had a
confederate flag an old english
tennessee and he started wiggling and he
was like when he had the confederate
flag that he goes oh this is a racist
he's like I'm not a racist he's like
it's just it's just I have southern
pride so that's exactly was all water
saying here in the situation cuz a lot
of people started attacking this family
saying like like what are you talking
about like you guys are hella races look
at all these photos with you and Keaton
like the mom with the Confederate flag
and then the kids too like the
Confederate flag is near there I don't
see anything wrong with that picture
I guess there's the there's people that
tie it to the southern slavery port Oh
what Tennessee was explaining to us is
that it's more of like
a rebel and then being like
anti-establishment and in like like that
part of it but not the racist history
part of it because he's against that
part yeah I just see it as like their
southern pride like it's just that
region yeah a lot of people don't don't
see it that way though so there's like
half and half right it's like the in and
out symbol for the Southwest people who
don't want to understand there's these
people's point of view they just look at
it as like like a bumper sticker this is
proudly racist yeah yeah yeah and that
that's what bothers me is it's always a
straw man thing that everyone has to do
it's like I have to burn that burn you
down because you like something that I
don't like right like when people like I
have a buddy who is saying every time
there's a gun violence thing that
happens he's like we got a fan every
[ __ ] gun take every [ __ ] gun away
right and he has only lived in in
mansions his entire life now he lives on
a [ __ ] wharf like like in a really
nice neighborhood like with a with a
controlled-access building like in one
of the lowest crime areas in LA so he
doesn't even know what it's like he has
no point of point of reference like as
far as like what what people who grew up
in other neighborhoods like had to deal
with so why they would feel the need to
be armed and like how if you call the
cops it takes 22 minutes on average for
them to come in LA yeah they don't know
that stuff because they live in like
paradise I have my private security
guard comes within like 10 seconds right
yeah why would you why would anyone need
a good when you have private security
which is exactly why every time there's
a say a school shooting or something
people really do go on social media and
they say you people who want to keep
your guns are for school shootings it's
the same [ __ ] here oh it's just like
dude you you just made a false
equivalency to something that because
you're too scared to actually open your
mind to what their point of view is but
are are they as their evidence of them
being like straight-up racist and like
calling people stuff so the mom
responded to that saying quote it was
meant to be ironic and funny I'm
genuinely truly sorry if I could take it
back I would
meaning what's ironic is like like she's
playing into the redneck mists of it
yeah pretty much like that so then she's
saying that she has spent most of her
life being judged because she wasn't
racist so she's just like trying to put
it out there like
I'm not racist at all these photos were
just a joke so yeah so then people were
just connecting the fact that this mom
has like all this evidence that she's
racist to the fact that Keaton was
getting bullied so now there are these
rumors saying that Keaton was saying the
n-word at school
oh ho he was getting bullied but there's
no evidence of that it's just like now
there's this rumor that's that's going
around and so Miss ESPN host her name's
Jamel Hill who's a black woman
she previously invited Keaton to the
studio but then after these images came
out she ended up saying this quote I've
seen her post and if it's true I'd say
there's potential for a great teachable
moment here my offer to Keaton to visit
ESPN stands because of what happened to
him was cruel that said this is a stark
example of selective empathy so a lot of
people are now like they were supporting
it but then because of this whole mom
thing they're like oh no like you must
be like that's where the son got it from
and so now they're like retracting their
support but then a lot of people are
saying like it's not about the mom it's
not about any of that it's like the fact
that this kid got bullied and we should
be against bullying so more ties to the
whole racism background thing is the
fact that Keaton's father his name is
Shaun White perfect like a snowboarder
that sucks to have that as your name
dude that's like his name is Bill Gates
and it's like he's [ __ ] did that so he
has a very clear history with racism
he is currently in prison until 2018
over aggravated assault charges he has
tattoos that's a pure-breed white pride
Arian me WB which stands for crazy white
boys gang
and so yes oh this is what the father
looks like Keaton's father he looks like
a very nice individual and it's a
hundred percent that's his dad because I
know the Internet does some crazy [ __ ]
no this isn't that so then the sister
said this quote you all can look back at
every tweet from every father's and
mother's day to see that all we have is
our mother we have no contact with our
dads because of their action hmm that's
why all the articles say is strange
because we don't talk to them leave us
alone
she's like constantly trying to defend
the family because they're getting so
much because sisters tweeting it this is
so another thing the point is that a
GoFundMe account was set up by a man
named Joseph Lam who he set it up in the
name of Keaton and he had raised $50,000
why does a bully kidney money yeah what
circle maybe college funds you can buy a
monster truck what the hell I don't get
why everyone needs to go fund me for
everything that happens so the reason
why you started this GoFundMe account
was because seeing Keaton cry really
touched his heart and so he wanted to
gather donations to help his future like
with college funds or anything like that
but then after this whole backlash
started they stopped accepting donations
$3,000 of the donations were funded to
people that no longer wanted to be
involved anymore and so the GoFundMe did
state though that none of the money was
going to Joan's family as of yet but oh
good
tours are going but mr. Lam is saying
that he plans to set up a $25,000
college fund for trust for Keeton and
then the rest of the money will go to
national anti-bullying programs okay and
so this is what mr. Lam said quote as
many of you know I posit donations as
well as the comments as I sit back and
read these comments and watch the video
again I feel I had to make this update
this is not about the mom however
passing judgment on her before you know
her is a form of bullying condemnation
before evaluation is the ultimate form
of ignorance I can't even say for sure
that any of what's being said is true I
don't know the family personally and
never claimed to have known them this is
about a kid who's been bullied and not
just one kid Keaton there are many
unspoken cases about kids being bullied
we have to be the voice for the
voiceless in the video I saw a kid
crying not just for himself but for
others to me that's a kid with a heart
of gold and deserves praise that's true
because like even if child Charles
Manson had a son and he got bullied it's
like it doesn't change the fact that the
kid got bullied like who cares who the
father is well yeah but this is what I
call selective compassion where it's
like it's like as long as you agree with
all of my moral issues like but like
we're chill but if I find out you drive
a gas-guzzling SUV and you got bully
you're the devil you're you're hurting
our earth and you're down with killing
our earth and like I don't want to help
you anymore like to me this is the kind
of thing that gets you to the point
where you're literally at a soup kitchen
some guy walks
and he's hungry and you had the soup out
on a ladle right and then you'd notice
that he has a tattoo of say it's a
swastika something that you think is
[ __ ] up like and you're like you know
what not for you
sorry well no but I'm what I'm saying is
is that it's it's not we don't know why
he had that he could have had it he
could have changed he could write he
could have had it years ago he you know
got involved with drugs he got involved
in a gang who the [ __ ] knows like I
don't know well what if it's like you
were at a soup kitchen and this guy
comes up to you is I call him super
hungry I just [ __ ] like 12
three-year-olds in the back right there
would you still well they're hard three
but they're like three years no what I'm
saying is is it's it's just like we
don't know the all the information I
don't know like it like is these do you
walk up with an affidavit and say I [ __ ]
these guys it's like like like do you do
you feed that guy in prison now look
like I'm just saying like there is this
like what's your purpose at the soup
kitchen and if that's your purpose it's
to be compassionate let's just be
compassionate and let the police do
their job there's different reasons for
people to do it and I think what do you
saying as I get for gonna contribute to
this kid being bullied
that's that isolated incident who cares
if his uncle is the Grand Master of the
KKK or whatever if you're really trying
to contribute to this kid because being
bullied and just contributed yeah
because people are doing it out of
selfishness if they're selective about
compassion they're like oh I just want
to help you out because you make me feel
good for helping this kind of person out
you don't make me feel good when I help
this other person out so I just feel
like the kid doesn't didn't choose his
upbringing
yeah upbringing his mother so what is
his mother's mistake have to do with him
being bullied I don't know what his mom
did she's holding up Confederate flags a
man clearly was dating the dad who
clearly has [ __ ] Aryan tattoos on him
so maybe she's either one she's a
dumbass or two she was a part of it too
she was okay with it
that's true it could be yeah but it's
yeah it's just guilty by association
right you can't drag the kid into it
yeah because what needs to happen is the
opposite where even if this family is
racist or whatnot if you give to them
and if you show them love
change their ideas but if you do the
opposite you confirm those ideas and say
oh well you guys are racist exact you
guys it's gonna keep creating this
divide so I think what yeah people just
need a [ __ ] give especially to me
[Laughter]
[Music]